to win the first one
i warned you about this guy ernie i want
you brady and rogers one up right out of
the gate
let me tell you tom brady's second at
the par five seconds
my goodness
there it is
good putt get up there
it's a nice putt this guy's pretty good
at golf
it's what happens when you don't go to
otas you just
[Laughter]
and then because of that
control the club face but this is good
right here is it gonna make it
come on
[Applause]
[Music]
a clear endorsement for drinking on the
course
[Laughter]
i asked josh earlier what his spirit
animal was and he said a golden
retriever
wow
right in the jaws man
alan and mahomes battling back we head
to the sixth the hall square our good
neighbors at the state farm have sent
out jake to help there he is
kevin chuck that miniaturized your head
look at that
that is actual size
right out of the dome took a little
piece out of it
oh my god
all right par for brady and rogers and
now mahomes and josh allen trying to
match
oh
that's a confident stroke right there
beauty
it could be the siding factor in this uh
match here
oh my goodness just painting edges
wow
oh backwards hat handing the ball back
to him swagger off the swagger off but
here we go
cut
cut
kick it off of it
that's got to be within 10 feet right
these guys have found their groove here
yeah
all right patrick mahomes 100 grand
donated defeating america for the lead
in the second hole in a row they've had
a chance to take the lead so they're
knocking on the door
oh nice pot big that's some confident
strokes with the putter old guys haven't
won in a while oh well it's the first
time today they've had the lead
they had won since two
yeah
aim small miss
what's your availability next week oh jj
uh after i get off tv today i'm
absolutely free for the next four months
perfect and that's going to feed back
what a shot and it's getting better oh
it might go in that might go in
forget these guys at one up
you were going to love that one patrick
i i hope so man i hope that things real
tight it is
[Music]
oh well done that's all right
that's a great answer by aaron rodgers
well somebody out there is a bad mother
look at that
spot on again
that was clutch
he's been solid man he's been solid come
on now come on now
come on
pressure applied by aaron rodgers and
answered by patrick mahomes they remain
just sitting next to you all day it
sounds like you don't ever hit a bunker
oh here we go guys here we go
we got a chance here
come on get on come on
nice shot aaron nice shot that's a
beauty right there this as long as i've
been in vegas without drinking in 30
years
oh wow look at that nice and smooth tom
brady good job boys never doubt the guy
nice george is a tie the going for the
green challenge we are all tied with two
to play all tied up how you feeling
ernie i told you earlier we're gonna
make a good tv
so uh me and josh just let him get back
into it real quick so we can go and
finish it off here at the end
it's tnt you know drama there you go
down get down
[Applause]
more finish oh nice
hey oh my goodness those must be bills
fans yeah look at that
for the lead with one to play
oh
it's a good putt
we are going to go to the 12th
all tied up talk about a
picturesque way to finish this thing off
a little back and forth action coming
right down to the end what more could
you want a perfect wedding
hit up there oh this is probably good
come on
wow
we were so close to seeing this guy in a
waterfall
charles started unbuttoning his shirt
alright so it comes down to uh aaron
rodgers and tom brady can one of them
make a putt
oh my god
he began the day with a birdie at the
first and he can close the door here on
number 12.
oh my god and he jumped why
yes sir
oh my god
wow
that's awesome i think about three feet
from the cup he knew that was going
straight down